(host)
Humans have
domesticated animals
as beasts of burden
for thousands of years.
And the vital role horses play
in the evolution of
culture in particular
has inspired countless
equine folklore.
But none are quite
like the centaur.
With the lower body of a horse
and upper body of a human,
they maybe should be dismissed
as a completely
impractical creature.
But even with dubious origins,
history has embraced
the lore of the centaur.
I'm Dr. Emily Zarka,
and this is "Monstrum."
A centaur is always
upper half human
and mostly always
lower half male horse.
The centaurs of antiquity
were not known to be docile,
quite the opposite.
They were violent meat
eating predatory creatures
that hunted and
terrorized humans.
In lore, the human
half of the centaur
often represents civility,
while the horse
half is bestiality
and uncontrollable desire.
Depictions of centaurs
trace the monster back
as far as the Babylonian
period in the 16th century BCE,
to when the Kassites
entered the Fertile Crescent
on horseback and seized control
of Southern Mesopotamia.
They used carved boundary
stones called kudurru
to indicate land transactions.
Some of these artifacts
depict centaurs,
a human man attached at
the torso to the body and legs
of a winged horse.
In examples produced
between 1186 to 1172 BCE
near what is now Iraq,
the centaurs are depicted
hunting with bows and weapons
and likely served as symbols
of protection or warning.
Kassite influence
likely extended
to the Aegean civilizations,
including the Mycenaean Greeks.
While it is unknown exactly
when their cultures interacted,
many scholars believe that
the two influenced one another
and they may have introduced
the idea of the centaur
to Greece where it really took
hold in folklore and culture.
The centaur began to
appear in Greek art
beginning in the
10th century BCE.
The Lefkandi Centaur
is believed to be
the oldest such example.
While all four legs of the
centaur appear to be hooved,
bronze and terracotta artifacts
from sixth and
eighth century BCE
show the centaur with the
full legged body of a man
with the rear end of a horse
seemingly grafted onto the back.
Around the eighth century BCE,
two centaur origin stories
dominate Greek texts,
the benevolent demigod Chiron,
the immortal instructor, and
the vicious race of Centaurs.
Chiron is the half-horse,
half-human son
of a nymph named Philyra and
the Greek god of time, Kronos.
Versions differ on who exactly
is genetically responsible
for Chiron's horse half.
In some versions, Philyra
desperately shape shifts
into a mare to avoid
Kronos' unwanted advances,
only to have him take
the form of a stallion
and attack her anyway.
In the other version,
the two are happily
engaged in an affair
until they are caught in the
act by Kronos' wife Rhea.
To avoid being caught,
the god of time quickly
shifted into a horse
to avoid his wife
identifying him.
Philyra is horrified when
she births a half horse baby
and abandons him.
Apollo and Artemis
take the child in
and under their
divine instruction,
the Chimera demigod
becomes a notable healer,
astrologer, hunter, and prophet.
He marries a nymph and they
have multiple children.
He also becomes a teacher
to infamous heroes Perseus,
Achilles and Heracles.
In the early fifth century,
ancient Greek poet Pindar
gives us the second canonical
centaur origin story,
that of Ixion and
the race of Centaurs
who are far less noble.
These creatures are the
grandchildren of Ixion,
king of the Lapiths and Nephele,
who's basically a cloud
made into a beautiful woman.
After Ixion assaults Nephele,
she gives birth to a unique son.
Depending on the story,
this is either
the first horse-human hybrid,
a true monster,
or a human man named Centaurus
who would eventually mate
with multiple Magnesian mares,
unions that all resulted in
herds of hybrid children.
Either way, it's a dark story.
The race of Centaurs
are often portrayed
as lust-filled drunk,
dangerous beings.
Sexual assault and violence
underscore almost
all encounters.
And that's before we get
into the Centauromachy,
or what I like to call
the bloody wedding.
The Centauromachy is a key
part of Greek mythology,
an epic battle between the
Centaurs and the Lapiths,
an Aeolian tribe, that
began when the hybrid race
got really drunk and tried
to rape all the women
at the wedding,
including the bride.
For the Greeks, the Centaur
race was a representation
of dangerous hyper-masculinity.
They can't hold their liquor
and they're physically
and sexually violent.
Homer refers to the
race of Centaurs
as mountain-bred animals.
For the ancient Greeks,
the mountains were
synonymous with danger,
directly opposing
the groomed fertile plains
associated with civilization.
The connection between
centaurs and sexuality,
particularly sex outside
of a marital union,
marks them as ready metaphors
condemning such practices
in the real world,
given that they are
also associated with
negative animality.
Just look at the Centaurs'
forefather Ixion.
He gets out of paying a dowry
by killing his father-in-law,
tries to seduce Zeus'
sister slash wife
and gets with a cloud,
not exactly a pillar
of the community.
And he ends up pinned to a
flaming wheel for all eternity.
The entire history
of the centaurs
from their very creation
is marked with negativity.
According to Greek lore,
all the centaurs were
slaughtered by Heracles
after a centaur named Nessus
tried to steal Heracles' bride.
Chiron tries to intervene,
but is grazed by
a poisoned arrow.
Unable to die but in great pain,
he exchanges his immortality
for Prometheus's freedom.
Upon his death, he is
placed in the stars
as the constellation
Centaurus or Sagittarius.
Chiron is the only exception
to centaurs' representation
of the supposedly
uncivilized other.
And the Greek's attempts
to demonize cultures
they found barbaric.
Unpredictable, on the
fringes of society,
and more animal than human,
they provide a ready scapegoat,
one that unfortunately would
be applied to real people.
Ancient Greek and Roman art
suggests that the centaurs
were metaphorical
exaggerated representations
of the Persians,
replacing real outsiders
with monstrous,
fictional outsiders.
It has also been argued
that the Centauromachy
may be a fictional
representation
of the real conflict
between the Argive and Theban
people before 1200 BCE.
Hailing from the Argos region,
the Argives were famous for
their horses and agriculture.
The aptly named city of Thebes
was an influential hub of trade.
The Parthenon in Greece
includes the Centauromachy
and its architecture.
The marble sculptures
depicting the monsters
as muscular threatening
opponents to the humans
rearing triumphantly
over their kills.
The temple of Apollo Epikourios
is also adorned with images
from the Centauromachy,
but the centaur's human
heads are older bearded men
and the assaults are
more sexually graphic.
In all these hard won
centaur human battles,
the Greek male
citizen triumphed,
emphasizing their importance
and visibility in Greek culture.
During and after the
real Persian Wars,
the creation of the
city-state or polis
bound Greeks together
with a centralized
democratic government
and a shared language.
Social hierarchy
within the polis
was determined by
birth and gender.
At the top, free adult
men born legitimately
to citizen parents, aka the
heroes of the Centaur stories.
Below them, foreigners
and foreign residents,
aka the centaurs.
In an effort to establish
legitimate citizenship
for Greek heirs, Greek men were
to marry virgin Greek women.
Foreigners, depicted
as centaurs,
threatened Greek
citizenship and government
with their sexual
lasciviousness.
There is some
argument to be made
about the novelty of
the rider on horseback
when such mounts were first
encountered by cultures
whose ecosystems did not
naturally include horses.
Whether seen first in
war, trade or conquest,
the shock of seeing
a human on horseback
may have given some
inspiration for the centaur.
To that point, some scholars
argue that the centaur myth
may be based on the
first mountain riders
in the Thessaly region,
pre-Trojan war tribes
believed to be named
Centaur and Lapith.
The Centaur people according
to Greek author Palaephatus
hailed from a village
named Nephele.
During Ixion's reign as king,
a herd of wild bulls
terrorized the region
and inhabitants of Nephele were
the only ones daring enough
to ride horses into
the herd of bulls,
slaying them with javelins.
After they were
rewarded by the king,
they turned hostile toward
the townspeople of Larissa,
called Lapiths, kidnapping
women and burning homes
before retreating
to the mountains.
But Palaephatus is known for
trying to rationalize myths,
so who really knows?
Other attempts to bring
the centaur to reality
include pre-Socratic Greek
philosopher Empedocles,
who proposed a theory
of human evolution
that included the centaurs
as part of ancient
generations of animals
that existed before
species differentiation.
There were also reports
of real centaurs.
In the early first century CE,
Roman Emperor
Claudius received word
that a centaur had been found.
Reportedly captured in Arabia
and transported to Egypt
as a gift for the emperor,
it was said that the
meat eating creature
did not survive the
change in climate.
After its death, it was
embalmed and sent to Rome.
Emperor Claudius displayed
the embalmed centaur
with a face fiercer
than a human face,
hairy arms and hands
and a tawny mane at his palace.
While this story
seems like fiction,
there is a bit of fact,
or rather trickery.
The supposed centaur
submerged in honey
was likely made from
the mummified remains
of humans and horses.
The honey not only
preserved the corpse
but would've been
difficult to look through.
A blurry centaur is
more easily believed.
The creature was still on
view nearly a century later.
You would think such hoaxes
would've faded with
the development of
biological studies.
But in the 1980s,
a supposed centaur skeleton
was exhibited in the US.
Created by zoologist William
Willers as a social experiment,
the remains now reside in
the John C. Hodges Library
at the University of
Tennessee-Knoxville
as an art installation.
Beginning in the
sixth century CE,
centaurs and satyrs became
increasingly conflated,
with the former disappearing
from the retelling of myths
even though their
image remained in art.
It seems the centaurs
were too supernatural,
too uncivilized.
However, in the Middle Ages,
centaurs began reappearing
in Christian churches.
Associated with bestial desires
or even the devil on
the hunt for souls,
they retained the negative
associations of the past.
Centaurs would go on to appear
in Dante's "Divine Comedy"
as the inhabitants
of the first ring
of the seventh circle of hell.
You know, the one with
the river of blood.
They stand on the banks
as jailers of the souls
boiling in the river,
shooting arrows at
any who try to escape.
Centaurs increasingly moved
from presumed fact to fiction.
By the 19th century,
interpretations of the centaur
focused on their
connection to nature,
with the creatures
personifying tornadoes
or mountain streams.
Centaurs today occupy
the fantasy genre,
appearing in books and movies
as dangerous but
fantastic creatures.
Given the genre's mass appeal
and often younger
target demographic,
the brutal violence,
particularly sexual violence,
is mostly downplayed in favor
of more culturally
digestible pieces
of the monster's
ancient origins.
In C.S. Lewis's
"Chronicles of Narnia,"
they are strong,
noble, bearded warriors
who fight for good along Aslan.
While physically imposing,
Lewis makes sure
centaur characters
are positioned as
educated civilized allies,
who excel in medicine
and reading the stars.
In J.K. Rowling's
Harry Potter series,
centaurs are likewise
intelligent healers
and quite skilled at archery,
astronomy, and divination.
Almost all choose to
remain apart from humans,
seeing them as
unworthy of attention
since they have already read
their fates in the stars.
Even though Rowling's
interpretation
attempts to make the
creatures respectable,
they are also portrayed
as wild and uncivilized
which takes a disturbing turn
when temporary Hogwarts
Headmistress Dolores Umbridge
is carried off by
centaurs into the woods
and returns
incapable of speaking
with bits of twigs and leaves
and her disheveled hair.
Rowling's centaurs seem
to retain as much of Ixion
as they do of Chiron.
I'm sorry Professor,
I must not tell lies.
What are you doing?!
(Dr. Zarka)
In Rick Riordan's
"Percy Jackson" series,
the original Chiron
of Greek myth
teaches the heroes of the story,
at first choosing to
hide the lower half
of his body with a blanket
and a wheeled box
with fake human legs.
In the books at least.
The Centaur race also appears,
described as talented
warriors and big partiers.
While threads of the
original centaurs linger,
today the centaur is
more commonly used
as a symbol that unites
rather than divides
humans and animals.
Because the centaur is
made from two beings
that really exist, not
entirely fictional beasts,
they are more
easily transmissible
and translatable across time.
Positive or negative,
they force us to
confront our relationship
with non-human animals
as both celebration
and condemnation of the
human animal relationship.
Wes, a bro--
a bronze arrowhead.
The brutal violence,
particularly sexual violence,
is mostly down paid-
Epikori--
It's definitely Epikourios.
Epikourios.
At first choosing to hide.